in alabama officials searching for a
murder suspect and his jailer released
surveillance video that seems to show
the moment they ran off together
authorities say the video shows
lauderdale county assistant director of
corrections vicki white taking suspected
killer casey white to a patrol car last
week the two who are not related have
been missing ever since the local
sheriff says the fugitives have had a
long history together as janet chameleon
reports
sheriff rick singleton now says vicki
white's relationship with inmate casey
white goes back as far as two years when
he was first held at the jail where she
worked he came back in february 22
and
in that interim while he was in prison
we have evidence that there was
communication between the two of us the
sheriff told us there's no evidence the
duo's relationship was physical but that
officer white offered the suspected
murderer special privileges like more
food which bothered other inmates
that revelation came shortly after law
enforcement released this footage they
say that's her guiding casey white in
shackles and handcuffs to the back seat
of a patrol car on friday
at the time authorities say officer
white claimed they were heading to a
mental health evaluation at the county
courthouse no such appointment was on
the books
what did you think when you saw that
video
well knowing that what was going to
transpire you know is sort of gut
wrenching really u.s marshals have now
released these pictures of white's
getaway car a 2007 orange or
copper-colored ford edge they say the
fugitives may be armed with an ar-15
rifle handguns and a shotgun you have
confidence that you will find officer
vicki white alive
i have concerns
that we might not this guy you know
i think he used her swooned her
into doing something that's totally out
of character for her
and i think the minute that
she becomes a a liability for him i'm
concerned of what he might do for cbs
mornings i'm janet schamelian
nation's watching that story